hey everyone we're at Blizzcon and me
and Phil just got to play at the habla
for and it was just announced today that
I think people knew was coming right
yeah a little bit but uh yeah I know
it's it's real we saw it and we got to
play it yeah got to smack some stuff
around as a druid and various forms of
being a bear so that was pretty fun
during the presentation they actually
talked about how this is more of a
return to the darker side of Diablo
which to me seemed like sort of a dig at
Diablo 3 which you know which is
something of a contentious title for a
lot of people particularly for the sort
of the vibrant color palette which may
have been you know not again not so much
in line with the first two Diablo games
did you actually get a chance to play
any of the previous games or I did a
little bit I you know I've dabbled in
Diablo over the years but yeah this is
the this seems like more of my speed I'm
kind of a horror game buff still like
this is the kind of Diablo that I'm
interested in yeah definitely like seems
like it's gonna get pretty bloody and I
finished one mission got all the things
done brought it you know everything back
to the kid who needed the thing and he
still died for somebody just like a
cocked up a bunch of blood it was it
seemed great yeah there's actually a
section in the beginning where you're
actually literally crawling through
bodies right just this massive pool of
blood that whole shot was like that's
the descent you know it was very much
also a Laura Croft a Lara Croft Tomb
reader kind of thing yeah like it's very
cool I was gonna do it and you know
what's interesting is that of course
it's very much in line with like the
previous Diablo games but that it's it's
got more of a sort of a online element
is you can say like a you know there's
one section where we went out to this
sort of wide open setting and you know
we saw like other players sort of like
wander in like yeah people are just like
out doing their thing they're running
around the same town as you they're you
know killing various monsters and
leaving goal for you to pick up which
was nice I appreciated that yeah it
seems more in line with kind of like the
live game sort of situation that we've
got going on right now where people are
kind of sprinkled in you go into like a
cave or a mission then you're in your
own instance it seems like but out in
the world seems like you're sharing the
world with a lot of other people which
is kind of cool
yeah it's very interesting like you know
because I'm used to playing you know
when there's other people it's like you
know it's it's a choice like you know
you you want to play with friends or
whatever but this one it's like it's
it's it's very much a shared world and
you know they actually leads up to some
of the world events that you can take
part in and uh you know that was a it
was interesting you know just sort of
seeing like you know how these massive
events just sort of happened right yeah
it gave me a bit of a Destiny feel yeah
right now like it's which I'm a big
destiny pencil like I was like oh I can
I can get behind this is cool yeah um
yeah but it seems like there's a lot of
like big stuff going on that you can
kind of choose to participate in or not
which is nice right and like I kind of
beelined a mission but I could see other
things going on that like could have
caught my eye if I if I'd wanted to go
off in that direction that's cool like
I'm into that yeah and the three
playable cast classes they had was the
Barbarian the sorceress and the drew
George seem to be the the favorite for
everyone so um you can actually
transform into a bear but also a
werewolf as well yeah you're like
constantly actually attacking people as
a working out it seems like you're
carrying around you know like a cudgel
but you're not actually ever using it it
seems like yeah and you also had wolves
do you like follow you around I'm like
you can direct after being in stuff so
yeah I know it's um it's very much like
sort of the more tactical classes I
guess you could say like yeah you can do
some really crazy stuff with that class
I mean it was very early in the game but
they sort of gave you like a you know a
certain set of skills that you can just
really go to town right yeah yeah it
gave me a sense of being something like
you're kind of inflicting status effects
on people as well as pummeling them it
seems like maybe what the druid is after
you know like throwing boulders at guys
and that kind of stuns them and knocks
them out of we're out of the fight a
little bit so you can kind of control
the rest of the action with the help of
your teammates right so and you know
just overall like I was really impressed
with like you know this is the game that
they had There and
so of course they just announced it but
they still had a pretty sort of media
you know sort of demo dive into it was
only I feel like there's only 10 or 15
minutes but it did you like a pretty
good slice of what we can expect you
open if it was you know just like one
town then one or two missions one or two
like public events yeah it seemed good
it seemed there were a lot of like
forlorn people to talk to
yeah you know a lot of cool little
monsters to kill and yeah yeah and you
know it seemed to have sort of like the
accessible elements of three but also
the more like sort of in depth bucks or
character building from right one and
two so yeah I know I'm Diablo 4 is like
you know something that I think maybe a
lot people were gonna be really excited
about and you know where both of us are
really excited to seeing more so yeah
definitely for more in Blizzcon stay
tuned the game spot
[Music]
you